so my name is Ron Worrell and I'm here
to talk to you today about how to build
anything with foundation TV I know that
sounds a little nuts I can't it can't be
literally everything because I'm only
here for a half-hour but I want to
provide you with some ideas and some
inspiration to tell you that even if
you're not super familiar with
foundation TV today that you can you
know dream up things that you can do in
the future and I want to give you the
foundations of of just like how do you
use keys and values to do stuff and
we're gonna do that with two examples
today the first one will be modeling
what looks like a relational database
schema which you are all very familiar
with by now after all the talks about
the record layer and some of the details
were in the couch TV layer as well and
the second problem is how to add
features to an existing distributed
system that doesn't provide super strong
guarantees and we're gonna do that by
adding consistent object listing
basically removing some of the problems
with Amazon s3 so when you when you
start using foundation TV you you get
you're basically dropped into a world
with nothing and you have to figure out
what to do yourself it's now quite
literally nothing because you have the
tuple air but it's not a whole lot and I
think this is a quote from Dave cher I'm
not entirely sure I think is from the
first open source thread on hacker news
when foundation to view is released and
this is the best description I have ever
seen of what it feels like to use
foundation DB what I want to do today is
give you the hammer and the nails with
which to take those 2x4 framing studs
and build a house or a database an
alternative way to look at it is you get
some Lego which is a little bit more fun
than building a house
so when we're talking about databases I
think we should you know I want to do
some definitions first and and you know
kind of map out where things fit and on
that screen the D probably doesn't come
across as
vibrantly images on my screen but those
are divided between blue and pink and
what we're going to be talking about
today is basically C in acid foundation
EB does the other stuff for you so what
is you know I you have to talk about
this for a second I'm not talking about
the C in the cap theorem that's not what
I'm talking about you know this this is
not what this talk is about this is
really not relevant for the first half
it'll be slightly more relevant for the
second half but again really not really
that's not the C I'm talking about this
is the C I'm talking about your program
brings the database from one valid state
to another emphasis on your program this
is your job so even you know even if
you're just building a like a rails app
on top of a sequel database it is still
your job at least partially and you need
the AI and D from acid in order to do
this and my my experience in the real
world this idea data corruption is is a
combination of bad application code as
in bugs that you alright in your
programs and bad databases and I'm sure
you've all experienced both some
problems are a bit hard to track down
whether it's one or the other but it's
it's definitely a combination of the two
and hopefully foundation TV gets rid of
the bad databases part so it's just your
bad code that's the problem now gotta
fix that so most databases provide you
with a few things in the C realm other
than a int which I already mentioned the
most important one I would say is no
false positives or negatives from index
lookups that one you kind of need if you
have indexes but again if this is your
layer that's your job
schema management like inserting and
indexing records and
some elements of type-checking not all
databases do that but a lot of them do
and foreign key like referential
integrity constraints not all databases
to support those either but if you're
gonna add that it's it's useful for
ensuring you know there are no bugs in
your and your program logic so how do
you create consistency and remember this
is consistency and the acid sense not in
the cap theorem sense so yeah you're
you're provided with a I and D and C is
your layers responsibility so how do you
do that so in the example today we're
gonna talk about a simple sequel like
schema it's not about any person any
particular database it's just a logical
model that we're gonna think about so
it's a bit oversimplified but it's not
too far off and I think the record layer
talks gave you a lot of information
about how to productionize that type of
thing so more definitions because again
there's these words are overloaded and a
lot of domains so what do I mean by a
database I mean a named container for
tables and some other things that I'm
not going to talk about but I'm just
going to call talk about tables today
what is a table a table is a name
container for indexes and attributes
what is an index it's a description of
how you transform a record into some
type of key that you're going to index
and what you're going to store in the
value and an attribute I think you all
kind of get that it's some field on some
record and that you're defining at the
layer of the table
what's a foreign key I kind of talked
about that before but but you you need a
way to manage the lifecycle and the
relationship between records across
tables a lot of databases enforce that
using enforce that using an index under
the hood even if you don't have one not
all I mean it's not in theory required
but that's a common way to do it so
using the tuple layer which is basically
the the thing that you get in the
bindings in order to structure your key
is a good idea to use the you could
think about modeling this as you've got
a database called school it's got a
table called students and an index that
is the primary index and the the value
that you store in this index key which
I'm going to explain a little bit more
is the value for that ID column and you
you can see this structure over here I
I'm gonna use this throughout the rest
of the section of the talk each one of
those blocks is some component in a in a
tuple and the way that I've the the
insight here that I think is may not be
obvious is that if you're trying to
think about how you model a sequel
database is the primary index is an
index like any other index and you can
put data in there like any other index
and it's not it's not necessarily some
special thing this is the kind of
creativity you have to have when
thinking about how you're gonna how
you're gonna model things so what about
a non primary index that's another index
too and as an aside here the the long
names in the components of the the tuple
are just for illustration purposes
you're not gonna actually do that in a
real layer until maybe you would with
redwood prefix compression but today
you'd probably use something like the
directory layer and turn those into
shorter prefix codes or something that
you do yourself there's a benefits of
doing this besides just prefix
compression that I'll talk about later
so remember when I said what an index is
it's some rules for transforming a
record into a key that you clear in an
index and a value that you store this
index is a non unique index you can
imagine some other person with my name
and some zip code I used to live in that
is also indexing in this table so you
need to store the primary key for the
record at the end so if you command
there's another person named Brian that
lived in zip code one zero zero seven
five they could have primary key two and
they could both live in the index so
that when you do a range scan you get
both records
so this is the the difference between
unique and a non unique index key on a
unique index you wouldn't put the
primary key necessarily in at the end of
the key there's this is you know things
that you can choose to do but it's a
method of ensuring that your index is
unique it's not about enforcing the rule
that's something that you do in your
code this is just a way to structure the
key you'd still presumably go read that
key and make sure that it actually
doesn't exist before you just blindly
write to it that's not the point of what
I am trying to illustrate just just the
key structure yeah so you you want to
keep the the the last value in the key
as the the primary key just again so
that when you do a range scan you get
them all back and you can dereference
them on the base table this was covered
in the couch TV talk today and it's it's
very important if your users expect your
data to come back in some some order
that's like a sword order that's innate
that's for their native language it's
not just the bite order you need to
support collation is what it's typically
called where you would store some type
of a representation that goes through
something like ICU to turn it into a key
that sorts well in for the database but
then you need to also store the
representation that the user would see
that's important for basically if your
if your app is gonna be used by people
that don't just speak English you need
to you need to do that so cockroach TV
which is a sequel database built on top
of a key value store has some
documentation about how they do this
which is very good because it's like a
real thing that works in the world and
it has lots of details just like the
record layer that you could that you
could go check out and I'm gonna re
upload a new version of this slides if
you saw them doesn't have this in it but
it will assume so you don't need to take
a picture or whatever yeah so the I mean
now I can explain to you why why you
would necessarily not just for prefix
compression benefits want to put some
type of indirection between the name of
a table for example in the
the idea of a table so if you wanted to
support renaming a table or any other
logical schema object you don't want to
have to rewrite the whole thing just
because you stuck it in the key that
would be annoying so there there are
benefits as well to to being able to do
that type of renaming and and you know
remapping it to some some ID the scheme
object another feature that you may want
in your lair is non-blocking schema
changes the consistent metadata
management feature added in 6:1 makes
this much easier than it would have been
in the past so I can actually explain it
in in 30 minutes so when I say
consistent again moving the database
from one valid state to the other
consistent in terms of the metadata
management is a that's the the cap
theorem type of consistency but that's
the one I'm talking about right now
so an index must not return false
negatives by allowing queries before it
is fully built that is a rule how does
the metadata version feature help so if
you version stamp the metadata object
that excuse me if you if you update the
metadata object and update the metadata
version key at the same time you can you
know as was described in the lightning
talk keep a keep the history of the
metadata and cash it in your layer so
you don't have to repeatedly read it out
of the database and cause a hotspot it's
stored at that key which everyone saw
earlier today and you use this to signal
that metadata has been changed in your
layer again this is stuff that you've
already seen you it's it's free to get
this key that's another thing they don't
want em sighs it's free to get this
because it's sent to you automatically
when you start a transaction in in
starting in 6 1 so the the paper that I
think Alex referred me to originally
about about how to do this is online
asynchronous schema changes in f1 from
from Google it's its f1 is their their
basically their sequel layer that
works on top of spanner which you know
that's roughly in a similar situation as
you would be in foundation TV so it it
makes sense it's a little bit tougher
for them because they don't have that
notion of a metadata version so the
paper goes into lots of complicated
rules about how to do this if you didn't
have the meditative version luckily you
can just implement the state machines in
the paper and it's a lot easier so I'm
gonna just describe adding an index
there's a whole bunch of other ones that
you can do that I'm not gonna describe
but basically you you have to update the
schema object and the meditative version
in the same transaction to signal that
the schema has changed you're doing this
in a transaction it's atomic just like
anything else so you set the initial
state to write only and this means it's
invisible to reads for other
transactions that are going on why does
it have to be invisible to reads because
it's being built that means if you serve
reads hermit it could serve false
negatives so as as new transactions
start after the metadata change happens
they do write in to this index again
they don't read from it and same thing
for for updates and deletes and in the
background you you know you do a back
some type of a back fill job to you add
the new the new records and one way to
fulfill this is to store the version of
the metadata that an object was written
with so that you know if it's like from
the older the new version of the schema
and you can do a big scan in the
background and and add it to the index
yeah so you use that version to detect
like if it's from before before after
the the background scan that's something
that Nicholas just mentioned is going to
be more parallel in the future version
of the record layer so again you can
reference the record layer for how to
implement these bits efficiently so when
you're finished with that background
scan and indexing all the records you
can update that metadata again along
with updating the metadata version to
say the index is ready for readwrite
traffic and then you're done and this is
a lot more this is a lot simpler than
what was just
in the paper because you don't like you
have access to that consistent metadata
version another feature that you may
want to implement because it's commonly
requested by business people is to have
change data capture so you can audit
changes to your tables the goal of this
is to log the before and after version
of every record that's inserted into the
database in the order that they were
changed in some type of a log structure
those of you who understand FTP you will
understand that this is hard this is not
a thing that you just get for free and
that's why I'm giving you a warning that
if you do this you really have to
understand what you're doing and do some
careful capacity planning because this
is basically like append only type
structure and if you fall pint while
you're moving this around say you're
gonna you know write it and then
periodically move it into some other
system if you fall behind you will run
out of disk space very rapidly so how
could you implement this in FTB again
this is this has performance
implications but depending on how
valuable it is to you this is a thing
that you can do so before you write to a
key which represents a record logically
like in the primary index of the table
you read it first so again this has
performance implications because you
have to do read before you do write and
it also has conflict implications
potentially you store the new the new
version of the record and the old
version together in another value in
some log looking thing using a version
stamped operation and the reason that
you can't do the read concurrently with
the write or after is because of the
read you writes cache will like you'll
just get back to value that you just
wrote and you that will not that will be
invalid for our goal here so when I when
I say old and new I keep saying those
words what are those mean bolder new
before and after is basically the same
the same thing for an insert before is
null because it's a new record and the
after is the inserted record if you've
seen the my sequel bin log or any type
of other database change log that's it
it should be somewhat familiar to you
but an update the before is the old
value after
a new value that one I think makes a lot
of sense for a delete the old the old
value of the before value excuse me
before is the old value and the after is
null because it's a record no longer is
this anymore so how would you implement
something like this this is again a
simplified key structure but the the
primary index and the change data
capture index are there again they're
they're just indexes and you can take
the old on the top you're imagining you
you read out that old value
you're gonna update it to the new value
you would write into the change data
capture index with a version stamp
operation both the old and the new value
such that you know in the future you can
go back and read it out in order so
another thing if you're familiar if
foundation you be you have to try to
avoid write hotspots you need to
structure your your rights to write to
multiple ranges at once so you don't
over overload one storage server in
order to read this log back out you have
to read every one of the partitions
starting between whatever version you're
trying to read and up to that future
version so this is a very naive way to
to do that just so spread the data out
pick a random number mod by the number
of partitions there's many more fancier
schemes that you could come up with
especially if you wanted to keep records
from the related records in the same in
the same logical partition oh the reason
why it should be of rr2 is because in
theory you can split and merge the
number of partitions you have basis
based on based on that if you don't pick
a power to that's partner view so a
feature request that I have which maybe
it's it's somewhat related to things
that are going on for backup but
exposing the the data on the T logs to
applications may be useful some people
may find it easier than been
implementing this thing it doesn't let
you get the before images but it lets
you get the after images which is maybe
more valuable to some people than them
before you could also implement this
thing on the storage server all again
and that's kind of crazy and it's it's
not free but that's another spot that
could that can
at this for you as a change feeds type
type feature this breaks the key value
abstraction once again in favor of
efficiency for for a high value use case
it's arguable if this is high value for
for you or not but that's just a common
theme especially with the query pushdown
feature that was that was talked about
this morning by Evan it's it's breaking
the abstraction in favor of a little bit
of efficiency so on to the the the
second half or last third I guess
however you want to call it but let me
describe to you why Amazon s3 is not fun
to work with and has a lot of
limitations these are quotes from the
documentation Amazon s3 offers eventual
consistency for overwrite puts and
deletes in all regions that doesn't
sound good
I'm not gonna read this one but but
basically it just says that object
listing is not consistent again not fun
to work with if you want to work
directly against s3 this one is not
obvious at all and if you make a request
s3 for an object that doesn't exist and
then you write into that object so your
speculatively hoping that an object will
be there at some point
future reads on that key will have
eventual consistency I don't know why
that's just a thing that it is maybe
they fix it and don't update the
documentation but yeah something gotta
live with this is this is basically the
the killer there's no conflict
resolution that like it's not there's no
locking basically if you're
simultaneously try to write to the same
key you better hope your timestamp is
later for the thing that you wrote
otherwise somebody else wins the thing
I'm going to talk about is that that
object locking mechanism that's somewhat
of what we're we're gonna build but
Foundation TV takes care of that that
bit for you so what can you do with s3
like what what actually does it give you
assuming you read-only already written
keys and you know for a fact that they
were already Rand
and assuming you never update them you
get consistent read after write that's
basically the only thing you do not get
consistent listing at all in any way so
that's not a lot if you want to operate
directly against s3 that's that's hard
to deal with so how do we fix listing
this one is kind of easy you just write
all objects to s3 first I'll describe a
little bit more about how you do that
and then you write a pointer to that
object into FTB so if you perform your
your equivalent of s3 list operations
using only foundation DB get range
requests you get consistent object
listing now there's there's lots of more
details that you can go into about this
to describe exactly the the semantics
that you want but but that's the that's
the gist but that's not the only thing
we need me a little bit more to make
this work so I'm not also assuming you
don't care about garbage collecting
failed puts s3 you can imagine some
scenario in which you successfully write
the s3 and you're gonna go then write it
to Foundation Navy but Foundation TV is
unavailable so you have like some
garbage data in s3 now that's a fixable
that not that interesting so the way
that you write objects now in s3 is you
just pick some UID key that is you know
random long unique and you wait for us
three to acknowledge that requests and
then you write that real key that you're
trying to write your object to into FDB
along with that pointer to s3 now you
could do something like conditional
writes like Google Cloud Storage can do
based on the metadata and the reason
Google Ad score storage can do that is
because Google Cloud Storage is backed
by spanner so how do you read out of
this structure
you just go to foundation DB first read
the key and then you read the pointer
out of s3 so it's a slightly slightly
more latency but really not that much s3
is not particularly fast to begin with
so how do you delete data out of this
you you add the pointer that was stored
in that key into some type of Q that
will ensure that it is eventually
deleted and then you delete the key
from foundation B all of what I just
described is basically how you can wrap
some other system in a you know a shell
of foundation DB that protects it from
all of its bad you know bad spots and
lets you get more features that make it
easier to program against so if you you
can imagine some type of analytics
application that works against data in
s3 that previously would have had to
deal with these artifacts of eventual
consistency by like retrying until it
saw what it expected to see all kinds of
other other tricks that now it could
somewhat avoid so go build stuff thank
you
[Applause]